schlacht um die macht tag 3 und an
diesem tag dreht sich die politik
komplett um 111 ii philippe piatti of
dazu bei uns im studio dieses evi ganz
genau es ist dieses kults elfi muss man
jetzt schon sagen es ist zwar erst
gestern abend aufgenommen aber ganz
deutschland spricht jetzt schon darüber
auf jeden fall das ganze politische
berlin man sieht die fdp spitze und die
grünen-spitze von links nach rechts fdp
generalsekretär volker wissing annalena
baerbock christian lindner und robert
habeck so starten also die
sondierungsgespräche
müssen noch gar nicht erst mal über das
politische sprechen sondern das was da
wirklich zu sehen ist und man weiß nicht
wo das alles aufgenommen wurde man will
nicht mal verraten wer das self gemacht
hat aber die körperhaltung von volker
wissing deutet daraufhin dass er das
selbst gemacht hat es sieht relativ
privat aus es könnte also eine
privatwohnung seien jetzt müsste man
wissen wer von denen hat denn wirklich
eine wohnung in berlin christian lindner
hat auf jeden fall eine und interessante
ist ja auch was was darunter steht
vielleicht kann ich das einmal vorlesen
ist ein ganz logischer text wie man das
aus der politik eigentlich gar nicht
kennt auf der suche nach einer neuen
regierung loten wir gemeinsamkeiten und
brücken über trennendes aus und finden
sogar welche spannende zeiten
wenn wir ein boot gedichte vorgetragen
in der schule das war richtig habe
militärische lehre absolut politische
lyrik ich tippe dass es der text von
robert habeck kommt ich glaube dass
christian lindner ihn auf jeden fall mit
abgesegnet hat denn das interessante ist
ja dass dieses 11 auf allen vier
accounts wissing berbalk lindner habeck
gleichzeitig mit dem gleichen text
gepostet wurde ich glaube ich man kann
ausschließen dass annalena baerbock das
geschrieben hat da war einfach die
plagiats gefahr zu hoch nicht dass das
sie ist es einfach wieder abgeschrieben
hätte ich glaube das kommt von den
machern dieses bündnis ist dieses citrus
bündnisses habig und lindner das ist
also sagt philippi adorf das mächtigste
self wie deutschlands das wichtigstes
elfi deutschlands auf jeden fall heute
und wir schauen uns einmal an was daraus
schon entstanden ist in diesen wenigen
stunden warum philipp jakob jetzt schon
sagt das ist ein absolutes kult self
[Musik]
also die neue politische familie da es
gibt ganz viele
kopien jetzt schon im netz von diesem
self das geht auf jeden fall jetzt schon
ins haus der geschichte ein in unsere
deutsche geschichte eines könnte der
anfang tatsächlich seien einer großen
politischen zusammenarbeit einer ganz
neuen politischen zusammenarbeit absolut
auch das was wir gerade gesehen haben
dieses kleine lustige video das geht
auch in der grünen spitzen in der
fdp-spitze schon viral ich habe das von
mehreren personen heute früh gleich
zugeschickt bekommen als guten morgen
gruß und hier mit diesem self ii beginnt
die neue erzählung die erzählung der
neuen koalition wir wissen nicht welches
sein wird ob jamaika oder ampel aber
dieses zentrale bündnis grüne und fdp
das beginnt mit diesem self mit diesem
vertrauens 11 man will ja wirklich
überhaupt nichts darüber verraten dass
alfie soll für sich stehen der text soll
für sich stehen man will nichts sagen
weder wo es aufgenommen wurde doch wann
es aufgenommen wurde wer das elfi
gemacht hat komplettes stillschweigen
dennoch sagt ja mehr eigentlich als
tausend worte denn wenn man das ist ja
auch bewusst jetzt diesmal die sozialen
medien genutzt alle vier haben das
gepostet alle vier haben es verbreitet
mit dem wissen dass alle es sehen werden
absolut man will die kontrolle
eingesetzt richtig man man will
natürlich ein zeichen dieser einigkeit
aussenden die einigkeit ist zwar noch
nicht wirklich da aber man muss die
einigkeit ja auch irgendwo herstellen
und zwar nicht nur untereinander sondern
man muss versuchen das auch der
öffentlichkeit zu zeigen dass man
zusammensteht dafür ist dieses elf
wieder philipp auf den tisch gestellt
haben wir hier mal ganz viel zitronen
limetten denn das was wir auf diesem
foto sehen nennen wir citrus citrus
koalition also ein ganz wichtiges
selbsthilfe deutschland warum so wichtig
so bedeutet ja es bestimmt ja jetzt den
fortgang der koalitionsbildung dieses
alfie ist der anfang der erzählung wie
wir regiert werden und die beiden
kleinen parteien grüne und fdp die aber
übrigens zusammen größer sind als cdu
oder spd die wollen jetzt ausloten
mit wem sie regieren wollen und erst mal
ob sie überhaupt selbst zusammenpassen
deswegen passt citrus so richtig denn es
ist nicht so leicht da zusammen zu
kommen da haben da gibt es so viel ist
aber sie könnte es könnten leute sauer
werden möglicherweise auch absolut genau
so ist es und deswegen dieses 11 dass
diese einigkeit verströmen soll alle
vier posten ist gleichzeitig mit dem
exakt gleichen text sagen dass die
differenzen überbrücken wollen so geht
es los wir sind jetzt offiziell der
wahlkampf ist dann mit diesem self
beendet wir sind jetzt in der
koalitionsbildung das sind die themen
bei denen es besonders sauer besonders
bitter werden könnte jetzt wollen wir
dieses selbst sehen das ja so viel
einigkeit und friede freude eierkuchen
so dass man hier falls katerina
zubereiten möchte aber eigentlich gibt
es hier so ein paar knackpunkte da wird
es für die vier die da jetzt stehen auch
wirklich richtig schwierig absolut die
beiden parteien haben total klare rote
linien aufgezeigt bei der fdp ist es vor
allem das steuerthema auf keinen fall
steuererhöhungen und im gegenteil
steuersenkung und die grünen fordern
eigentlich genau das gegenteil die
grünen haben wir aber ihrerseits wieder
ein thema das sie natürlich unter den
nägeln brennt völlig klar klimaschutz
und zwar nicht hier und da ein bisschen
mehr sondern das volle programm
dafür kam ist man auch bereits schulden
aufzunehmen der staat will zeigen wohin
es geht und der markt geht hinterher da
ist wirklich das kann ein linker
eigentlich nicht akzeptieren deswegen
hilft so 111 dass alfie geht heute durch
deutschland das rad durch die sozialen
netzwerke das self wie das hier für
diese citrus koalition stehen soll
stehen wird das hat jetzt schon totalen
kultstatus schauen wir mal rein was
dieses elfi jetzt schon ausgelöst hat
zum beispiel dieses video nämlich
[Musik]
also muss man natürlich sagen nicht von
den vier so zum video gemacht mit we are
family aber dass daraus entstanden denn
das ist ja natürlich genau die botschaft
politisch lass uns noch mal genau bei
diesem safe bleiben was wissen wir
darüber also wo es aufgenommen wer hat s
gemacht wann ist es gemacht worden und
warum von allen vieren genau
gleichzeitig mit demselben text ja also
das besondere an diesem self ist ist es
einerseits das wichtigste das am meisten
diskutierte self und gleichzeitig das
geheimnisvollste denn die vier wollen
nichts darüber verraten die wollen nicht
einmal sagen wer das self ii aufgenommen
hat auch deutet einiges darauf hin dass
können wir noch mal zeigen auch nochmals
dass die vier ins tabus von allen vier
wirklich zeitgleich gestern am ganz
späten abend raus gegangen das hat jetzt
schon so
160000 likes etwa im netz und wir haben
auch einen filter draufgelegt das finde
ich auch immer interessant jetzt muss
ich noch mal hier augen zu hören
schlecht aber davon nur noch mal ein
bisschen fitter nochmal schöner gemacht
das licht ein bisschen wärmer nicht
jeder hat einfach so gelassen annalena
baerbock hat sagen ein bisschen warme
farben noch material und es deutet
einiges darauf hin ist jetzt auch kein
geheimnis also christian lindner kann es
eigentlich nicht gemacht haben würde ich
jetzt mal ganz geheimnisvoll sagen das
ist ja biologisch sehr sehr schwer
umsetzbar aus der position ist deutet
auf volker wissing ist die körperhaltung
spricht eigentlich für volker wissing
theoretisch könnte es auch robert habeck
gemacht haben dafür steht er ein kleines
bisschen zu locker da aber vielleicht
ist das ja robe das große talent von
robert habeck in jeder situation selbst
beim self ihr noch total entspannt da zu
stehen aber ich glaube die
körperspannung diese leichte schräge
deutete folge wissingen aber selbst das
gehütet wie ein staatsgeheimnis und der
text der dazu gepostet wurde was würdest
du sagen woher stammt der der ist ja
auch bei allen vieren genau derselbe
text wonach genommen das genau auf der
suche nach einer neuen regierung loten
wir gemeinsamkeiten und brücken über
trennendes aus und finden sogar welche
spannende zeiten wirklich das hört sich
für mich nach robert habeck an robert
habeck ist ja buchautor auch
kinderbuchautor er ist philosoph und
diese diese weiche sprache das ist für
mich ein welchen klassischer habeck aber
das garantiert nicht alleine geschrieben
und veröffentlicht und entschieden
sondern da muss christian lindner auch
ein wort mitgeredet also da schon der
erste kompromiss den die vier zusammen
machen können ob ihnen jedes foto und
wir nehmen diesen texten und das wo hast
du irgendwelche hinweise wo das
aufgenommen wurde das sieht ja auf jeden
fall nach privater atmosphäre aus das
ist jetzt nicht in den räumlichkeiten
des bundestags ganz offenbar so sieht es
nicht aus das sieht nach einer offenbar
ja berliner wohnung aus wir wissen von
allen vieren dass sich aktuell hier
aufhalten also das kann nirgendwo anders
gewesen sein was was spekuliert du
wonach sieht das aus bei wem das
aufgenommen wurde also es sieht nach
einer privatwohnung aus und es sieht
nach einer sehr gut bürgerlichen
privatwohnung aus wenn man sich so bei
allen vieren konnte das sagen richtig
absolut die frage ist natürlich ist ja
auch der lebensstil wohnt robert habeck
so klar ist es auch ein gemachter mann
mit einem tollen gehalt seit vielen
jahren aber die wohnung von robert
habeck stellt man sich vielleicht ein
bisschen anders vor etwas bunter
mitbringsel aus aller welt viele bilder
so stelle ich mir zumindest robert
habeck vor christian lindner gilt ja
eher so als er wohnt ein bisschen
gediegener ein bisschen schicker sehr
stilvoll daher es könnte seine wohnung
seine gucken kabeln als israelischer cat
aus wenn er zu hause bist oder nicht
wieder so ein bisschen gegen christian
mit dabei wenn du zu hause ankommt was
als erstes so als gäste oder empfiehlt
vielleicht wird man bei christian endter
so förmlich zu hause begrüßt ich kann
mir vorstellen dass christian lindner
sein jackett aus hatte während man
gesprochen hat
muss dass er muss das jackett an
christian lindner und jackett das kann
man nicht voneinander trennen genauso
wie robert habeck natürlich keins trägt
klassisch in seinem schwarzen hemd und
annalena baerbock die da in der mitte
dieses selbst steht steht aber halt
nicht mehr in der mitte dieses
machtpokers liebe citrus freunde falls
sie weitere details haben zu diesem foto
bitte melden sie sich gerne auf paul
ronzheimer als handy falls sie mögen die
nummer kennen sie aber sie haben ja bis
hierhin stillschweigen offenbar darüber
vereinbart dass haben uns alle vier auch
bestätigt man will nicht dass das läuft
wie 217 das ist in den köpfen von allen
wir alle kennen doch diese fotos als da
sondiert wurde wurde für eine dreier
konstellation beim vergangenen mal und
dann ging diese balkon bilder ja durch
deutschland durch die welt in der
parlamentarischen gesellschaft hier
sehen wir volker bouffier hier sehen wir
vor allen dingen christian lindner in
der mitte neben wolfgang kubicki und
katrin göring eckardt horst seehofer
natürlich dabei alexander dobrindt diese
fotos da wurde noch mal eine gerupft auf
dem balkon diese fotos von fotografen
geschossen also gab genauso ganz viele
fotos damals bei social media daraus ist
einst entstanden vom balkon und von
innen immer wieder inside informationen
fotos damals nach außen gedrungen aus
der parlamentarischen gesellschaft
gegenüber vom reichstagsgebäude damals
auch christian lindner halt fleißig
getwittert das können wir auch gleich
noch mal zeigen viele teilnehmer damals
ständig fotos rausgeschickt robert
habeck haben wir damals gesehen wie er
im hoodie geschlafen hat auf den gängen
der parlamentarischen gesellschaft und
so weiter das will man diesmal ganz
gezielt anders machen findet ganz genau
diese jamaica verhandlungen 2017 die
wurden dafür berühmt dass so viel heraus
gestochen wurde und zwar nicht einfach
nur um uns zu unterhalten
nicht um kontakte mit journalisten zu
fliegen sondern jeder wollte seinen spin
hier sehen wir bereiten das ist robert
habeck und hier der puls damals von
christian lindner also einer der post
hier sehen wir noch mal das ist ein
roberto die das ist ein roberto die so
kann man das sagen und auch diese fotos
sind ja hochpolitisch ein politiker der
sich die nächte um die ohren schlägt der
da schläft wo er arbeitet und am
nächsten morgen weiter zu machen also
alle teilnehmer dieser jamaika fanden
2017 haben diese verhandlungen genutzt
um sich selbst auch zu profilieren um
ihre geschichte zu erzählen und die
wissen jetzt glaube ich das geht diesmal
nicht das wird dann wieder scheitern
deswegen macht man um dieses foto ja
auch so ein geheimnis deswegen will man
nicht verraten wo und wann und von wem
es aufgenommen wurde weil mit jedem es
fängt ja immer mit dem detail an
irgendjemand sagt ja es war der wissing
und wenn wir das dann berichten dann
fragen sich die anderen drei woher
wissen sie das denn wenn der der bild
irgendwas erzählt oder einem anderen
medium wer weiß was der dann noch
preisgeben deswegen dieser
stillschweigen packt um dieses vertrauen
zumindest beim ersten self komplett zu
wahren er ist elfi packt das könnte die
erzählung sein einer neuen citrus
koalition patricia schauen wir noch
einmal drauf auf dieses elfi das uns
dass deutschland so bewegt heute hiermit
hat etwas zu tun mit den zitrusfrüchten
mit limetten und zitronen und das nicht
etwa weil die 4 da irgendwie sauer
dreinschauen entgegen so hätten alle
lächeln ganz entspannt in die kamera und
sie haben ja auch allen grund dazu denn
sie sind nicht etwa die macher von
paypal sondern sie sind die königsmacher
sie sind diejenigen die entscheiden wie
es in deutschland weitergeht und dieses
foto haben sie gepostet alle mit dem
gleichen text mancher hat einen filter
drauf gelegt damit die gesichtskonturen
noch weicher sind als eh schon und
dieses foto darüber spricht heute morgen
deutschland und wir analysieren das
jetzt diese politische bedeutung dieser
citrus koalition kann da zusammen passen
was eigentlich nicht zusammen gehört
philippi ad hoc macht eine analyse der
citrus theme und der citrus person
ja die zitrus koalition im politischen
schnell check wir haben mal fünf
zentrale themen identifiziert und wollen
einmal drüber sprechen passen habeck und
lindner eigentlich zusammen fangen wir
beim thema bürgerrechte an beide
parteien zählen sich als progressiv
beide parteien haben eine starke bürger
rechtsgeschichte hier sind sie
eigentlich relativ nahe beieinander
außer bei einem kulturellen thema die
grünen sind die absoluten gender partei
die fdp haben sich kritisch beim thema
gender positioniert also bürgerrechte
auf jeden fall das kulturelle etwas
schwierig dennoch relativ nah
beieinander würde ich sagen dann das
thema digitalisierung hier muss man
sagen wir haben beide eigentlich nur
etwas zu gewinnen die große koalition
hat ein absolutes brachland hinterlassen
beide parteien stehen für
digitalisierung für aufbruch für dieses
start-up mentalität also ich glaube hier
wird man sehr einer sehr sehr nahe
zueinander rücken dann klimaschutz hier
wird es wieder deutlich angespannter
denn für beide parteien ist es dieses
thema zentral vor allem natürlich für
die grünen die getrieben werden von der
straße von friday is for future die
jahrelang opposition gemacht haben
oppositionspolitik mit der forderung
nach immer mehr klimaschutz und mit zwar
auch mit verboten mit der immer teurer
politik und gleichzeitig die liberalen
die sagen der markt muss entscheiden
deswegen hier könnte es knallen
hier stehen die beiden etwas weiter
auseinander
dann kommen wir zum thema steuern auch
hier kann es knallen vor allem weil die
fdp schon gesagt hat wir haben hier ganz
klare rote linien wir wollen keine
steuererhöhung wir wollen keine
vermögensabgabe sondern im gegenteil wir
wollen die menschen entlasten die grünen
stehen wirklich komplett anders die
grünen sind sowohl für eine
vermögensabgabe als auch für
steuererhöhungen vor allem für
besserverdienende und da die fdp diese
rote linie 1 gezogen hat muss hier
irgendjemand über seinen schatten
springen auch hier absolutes
konfliktpotenzial und dann das letzte
thema migration beide wollen aus
deutschland eine moderne
zuwanderungsgesetz schafft machen klar
passt kein problem aber wenn es um die
kritischen fragen geht um abschiebung
auch im abschiebung beispielsweise nach
afghanistan da wird es wirklich kritisch
fdp vize wolfgang kubicki hat bei bild
sofort nach dem fall von kabul gesagt
abschiebung nach afghanistan müssten
möglich sein dass es für die grünen
fallen für den linken flügel eine
absolute horrorvorstellung das heißt
beim thema migration flüchtlinge
abschiebung da kann es auch wieder
knallen da stehen die beiden so weit
auseinander
[Musik]